middle of these nationwide protests and
the corona virus pandemic on top of that
seven states and Washington DC held
primary elections yesterday
it'll keep his covering campaign 2020
and what did the voters decide
well good morning Gail for one thing Joe
Biden is inching closer to the
Democratic presidential nomination we
still have to call him the presumed
nominee because he hasn't earned enough
delegates but he's expected to do so
with two primary scheduled for next week
there were other notable contests last
night for example in Iowa Republican
Congressman Steve King who has served
nine terms won't get to serve a tenth he
lost a crowded Republican primary last
night to state senator Randi Feenstra
Republican leaders had stripped King of
all of his committee assignments last
year after he questioned why the term
white nationalism is offensive and the
city of Ferguson Missouri just elected
its first black mayor Ella Jones she's
also the city's first female mayor
Ferguson as you'll remember was the
location of the 2014 shooting death of
Michael Brown and unarmed black teen by
a white police officer and then there's
new controversy this morning over the
site of the Republican National
Convention President Trump tweeted last
night that the Republican Party is being
forced to move out of North Carolina
because of the state's Democratic
governor he said that Roy Cooper could
not guarantee that Republicans can use
the spectrum arena in Charlotte as
originally planned and he said he would
be forced to seek another state as host
governor Cooper says that he would be
happy if Republicans held a scaled-down
convention down from the plans that
included 50,000 attendees in order to
comply with coronavirus restrictions the
Republican Party now looking at sites in
Nashville Florida and Georgia as
possible alternatives the Republican
governors of those states would be happy
to have the convention but mayors and
several cities in those states have said
no thank you
Anthony Convention and Limbo ed thank
you very much